as the skies darkened over this summit
so did the mood with the news from
kremenchuk and a sombra assessment from
ukraine's leader
president zielinski told the g7 his
country urgently needs more help
they look relaxed but their mission here
is deadly serious maintaining unity five
months into this war
a smiling prime minister has left his
domestic troubles at home but also knows
he's winning the argument with france
and germany that now is not the time to
negotiate with putin there is no deal
that uh the president zalenski can can
really do so in those circumstances the
g7 uh supporters of ukraine around the
world have to continue to to help the
ukrainians to to rebuild their economy
to get their grain out to export their
grain and of course we have to help them
to
protect themselves
as g7 leaders joined others from
developing nations for a family photo
one of the biggest changes in the
western alliance in years was announced
elsewhere
we will transform the nato response
force
and increase the number of our high
readiness forces to well over
300 000
together this constitutes the biggest
overhaul of our collective defense
and deterrence since the cold war
nato is increasing its rapid response
force more than sevenfold and bolstering
troop numbers in the baltics
a radical shift prompted by russia's
aggression against ukraine
vladimir putin wants less nato he's
ending up now with a lot more of it on
his borders another of his strategic
objectives is dividing the western
alliance it's gone to great lengths to
appear united here it's leaders at pains
to show they're the closest of allies
but they are different countries being
tested by this conflict in different
ways keeping together as the war grinds
on for months to come will be a
challenge they can't afford to lose
dominic waghorn sky news bavaria